[Music]
right let's go out to Idaho and talk to
Mike Mike Mike Mike Mike what's up dude
howy uh not much just taking a break
from work to talk to you guys very cool
man I'm glad you called dude what's up
um yeah well I uh so I want to start
this off with I love my family and I
love my wife I know she loves me um but
I'm going to I'm going to kind of just
dump some stuff on and then we'll see
where we go from there it um so we have
a we have a 15-month-old son and another
one on the way and um you know we we've
been together for gosh going on six
years now and um you know we're we're
pretty passionate about each other we're
very aligned value wise very faithful
people but um you know the one area
where we we have some issues is uh the
bedroom and you know even when she's not
pregnant like I'm struggling to be
intimate with my wife and um you know
she says strugling to be intimate you're
struggling with like erections or she is
not interested in sex no she's not
interested in sex at all like she says
there are more than more than one way to
express making love and you know you
don't need to have sex to make love and
I'm like well you kind of
do I you know and and she says if you
did more romantic things for me you know
it would it would make a difference with
regards to how often we have sex and
like I try and make advances on her and
she like swats me away and there's more
to it than that like you know I know
she's become kind of insecure since
we've been together and there's some
stuff going on with like her childhood
and her parents and you know be specific
so I you you you threw a little piece
out that I've got um some opinions on
but there sounds like there's a bigger
Pi well actually let's do this let's
approach step one and then I want to dig
into the other stuff so step
one I
think the idea that women have a lower
sex drive than men is an absolute myth
it's not real it's not true or that
women have something called a sex drive
which is a myth that and it is just male
sex drive
light right none of that is true if you
look at the literature and you look at
um the studies done what is true is sex
and desire how those things are all
woven together um think of it as um this
comes straight from Dr Emily nagy's work
um I recommend your wife read a book um
called come as you are it is incredible
it's got a I probably wouldn't have made
that cover but the um book is
extraordinary um and it's just a master
class of all the things
that millions and millions of women
didn't get I also think it's a good read
for men too but it's written to women
about women's health and women's sexual
health but here's how what she describes
it she kind of pulls apart the myth of
sex drive and instead paints a picture
that sex is a series or desire is a
series of breakes and gas
pedals and if you think of it that way
for you gas pedals might be a wink it
might be just thinking of your wife it
might be um somebody attractive walks by
you at work and suddenly you're like oh
this is happening tonight right your
whole life is gas pedals for other
people there might their environment
might be a bunch of breaks got to make
sure the kid is doing this I've got to
make sure um this kid is fed I got to
make sure I'm healthy I got to go for my
walk I got to make sure the dish is set
up cuz I want to be a good wife and I
this picture of what wife looks like and
my husband and I have never talked about
it and then you come home and you start
pawing at her or doing you bring home a
flower you might think you are being
romantic here's your gesture and that
might have nothing to do with her
breakes and gas
pedals and so where I see people miss
each other all the time is she says I
need you to be more affectionate if you
were more
affectionate then I would want to have
sex more and you go into your toolbox of
affectionate that is probably a mix
of and I'm just not pointing at you I'm
say I'm speaking you as males in general
okay a mix of pornography a mix of
conversations you've had maybe a couple
of old girlfriends and just
some
imagination and you dip into that
toolkit and you're like all right
affection here we come and maybe your
mom made you want watch a Hallmark movie
Once and that Guy brought flowers and
you're like all right that sounds cool
and what you do is you miss the whole
boat and what I've seen couples
dramatically turn their sex lives around
by Simply Having the conversation about
gas pedals and
brakes and I'll just give you a story
from my own house I really took it
personally that my
wife had to have the kitchen
clean before anything could
happen and I put the math in my head
that she thought a clean kitchen was
more valuable than smoke show McGee over
here come to find out she had some
stories in her head about what a good
wife was and what a homaker supposed to
do and all this this baggage she was
carrying around I had no idea she was
carrying around and so once we sat down
and talked it
through dude you know what I love doing
now the
dishes right I I like things that I
never would would have assumed are about
affection or about you see me and or
help with bed times or take care of the
dogs or whatever the things are right so
there's that's a whole thing that is
worthy of a conversation that y'all need
to sit down and have what does affection
mean to
you and you're going to be probably
shocked that it has very little to do
with touching and looking and all that
stuff it has to do with an environment
right we we've definitely had those
conversations and her ideas of romance
are like you know us taking the truck
out and looking at the stars yep have
you tried that you know um you know it's
funny she's told me that since day one
we've never done it just for whatever
reason I don't want to do it bro she
gave you the road map I know I know that
one that one's totally on me I've
definitely made mistakes you're like one
of the few that know what to do
unbelievable can't believe you're
calling me all right so tell me about
the other stuff about family stuff and
childhood trauma well so the the other
thing is she she she's told me this
repeatedly she knew I was making this
this call okay and um she said I can't
keep a secret for my life and she's like
uh she said she hates sex like
vehemently even when we were having sex
a lot uh before we were married um you
know she said I I've never enjoyed it I
only did it because of you and because I
love you and I think that has a lot to
do with I mean I'm the only sexual
partner she's ever had I've had more
than one uh prior to us being married
and then um you know also her parents
very I mean they divorced they had a lot
of issues um and you want me to be
specific they
uh they did things that parents
shouldn't do uh with their children like
take them to bars at 2 A.M and have the
six-year-old drive them home like uh
that's probably the most blatant example
um and just a lot of irresponsibility
and vilification of a relationship and
um I think that's affected her greatly
and we we've seen a counselor and that
came up but you know she wasn't able to
really delve into it um for whatever
reason she doesn't like talking about
herself or her own problems um so that's
kind of where we're at like I don't I
you know I've told her like we need to
be I agree I need to be stepping up in
the romance department but you know
there needs to be some give and take on
your end and she's like I just don't
enjoy it like I I don't want to be
touched down there and I don't wish to
it hurts and I don't enjoy it at all I
get nothing out of it I was like gez
well that sucks well and so here's a
couple of things that happened number
one men almost always take that very
personally yeah and they forecast it
into the next 20 years oh oh c because I
don't know any guy who wants to hurt his
wife right but also I don't know any guy
wants to be married for 20 years and not
have sex I don't know any I don't know
women who I I mean I know they're there
I know there's there's all kinds of of
different um sexual appetites right but
very few people don't want to be
intimate for 20 years right and so your
challenge is to a not take this
personally it's not about like if you
were hotter or whatever or it's an
insult to you this is somebody saying
hey it hurts this is somebody saying
there's a lot of psychological baggage
potentially here I also can't
imagine that in this partic and and
let's just be super
clear if I sat down with her my guess is
it wouldn't only be going out in the
truck and looking at the
stars which is a proxy for I just want
to be with you and you're like that's
cool let's do it and suddenly this act
of sex might become the thing that she
grows to
hate because she feels like you don't
listen to her you don't you don't care
about her
you you care about taking care of your
needs and she is the vehicle by which
you do that right who knows but I think
it's really important for her to go see
a doctor and figure out the pain because
I start thinking about PCOS I start
thinking about uh endometriosis uh
fibroids there's all kind of stuff going
on has she done
that um I don't think so like we she she
got checked she had a bunch of
concussions in high school and she got
checked like up and down but I don't
know that she got checked for that dude
here's how this here's how the
conversation goes she goes to her doctor
and says I hate
sex okay and the doctor says give me
some more information and I promise you
she's going to be more open with her
doctor than with you a you sound like
your head's filled with cement B um they
have a relationship especially with
OBGYN doctors delivered her babies
doctors walked her along through one
pregnancy now into the second one and so
they're going to have a different
conversation but it has to be that that
blunt she has to tell the truth to her
doctor gotcha and honestly if if this is
my wife this is my sister this my friend
this is where I would recommend you
start start with your with your
doctor okay the challenge is she might
look at you and say I don't want
to and that's hard that'll be a hard
scary conversation to have
well she said that before I mean when we
went to counseling she she didn't want
to go because she doesn't like talking
about her feelings and you know it's not
a priority I mean we've got another kid
on the way
so there's that yeah it's it's super
super big time of priority sounds like
there honestly it sounds like there is a
lot going on and sex is one of the
lights on the dashboard telling you that
things aren't
okay well I mean overall we're we're
pretty happy I I mean we we have a
pretty nice home we have good jobs dude
bro you are missing it like by a hundred
miles oh okay like by a long shot
there's a couple of women listening to
this right now and they're both they're
nodding their
heads oh well I mean what do you
mean I mean you are have a picture in
your head of we're doing fine which
means what's a dollar amount what's a
square footage amount what is a safety
amount what is a how many times a week I
exercise and she's gonna tell you doing
okay is do you hear
me yeah and you're gonna go ah look how
nice our house
is hey can we do this and this and this
and this
please let's just do
it hey this hurts
like I don't like it I hate it it hurts
I don't want to talk about my
feelings yeah you're going to go talk
about your feelings we got to do
this that sounds like somebody who's
screaming for somebody to give them a
safe space to
talk if you if you were like my close
buddy here's what I would tell you to do
I would tell you to take a knee and what
I mean by that is I would take my wife
out in the
truck and some stars and I would hold
her hand and I would
say after I talked to this podcaster I
realized I've missed the
boat and I haven't heard you or seen you
for all of our
marriage and I thought about getting
great jobs and I thought about mechanics
and I thought about
needs and for some reason I didn't hear
you I'm sorry
I want to have sex with you I want to be
intimate with you I want that to be a an
important part of our
relationship but beneath that I want you
to know I hear you and I see you and I
love you
anyway and my brother that's where you
got to
start because at some point when are you
going to lose your job at some point one
of you or both of you is going to quit
working and you're going to do something
else
and you got to have a way stronger
Foundation than
that but try that and if if if it
doesn't go well call me back and say
you're an idiot I took a knee and from
my wife told her I was sorry asked her
what does she need what does she want
and I started not doing any of the
things in my toolkit I started doing
exactly what she
said started helping her with the home I
started helping with relationship stuff
I started holding her hand I started
doing these things
and then I asked her on behalf of you
behalf of our kids on behalf of me would
you go to the doctor and tell them that
you hate sex and that pain it's painful
it
hurts would you do that please I love
you that
much and I'm asking you to love me that
much let's see what happens
there take a e
brother I have a sneaking suspicion that
um the whole whole concept around
intimacy is way way bigger than what's
going on in your bedroom right
now and let me add this if she won't go
to counseling you can still
go because what you're doing is not
working let's try find some new
tools check out that book I'll link to
it in the show notes Come As You Are by
Dr Emily
nski um it is phenomenal it's a great
way to start a conversation in your
marriage